[Music]
welcome to a dynamic video that will
showcase the national library of
medicine's efforts to support seven
awardees as they use new technology to
raise awareness and disseminate HIV and
AIDS information there is roughly a
million people living with HIV in the US
and one in seven of them don't even know
it
this video rail will capture the
innovative process each awardee took to
spread awareness about HIV prevention
and treatment we will show you how each
awardee organization created and
executed their NLM project information
so let's start with the awardees in the
Big Apple he threw up his arms to the
ceiling and looked up and said there is
no cure for AIDS and there never will be
he said I can't take handling so many
young people dying he said I just cannot
take it in 1994 at the height of the
AIDS epidemic paws magazine founded in
New York City was first published pause
it stands for being HIV positive it was
also a time where there was a lot of
death and a lot of suffering so it was a
very bad environment to be tested
positive Oreo Gutierrez was diagnosed
with HIV in the 90s and has been an avid
reader of the magazine since its
inception for years and this magazine
has been a resource for him to learn how
to survive with the virus I didn't think
that I would see the age of three
and now is the editor-in-chief across
the nation why magazine reaches over a
hundred and twenty five thousand people
with each issue and has an online
version
pause calm which gets more than five
million pageviews a half paws covers a
wide spectrum of needs of people living
with and affected by HIV and AIDS but
when it comes to online there's also a
portion of people that we still want to
engage with with better that certainly
people that are more tech-savvy younger
people people that are at risk for HIV
who are not necessarily living with the
virus but need more information HIV and
AIDS information from the national
library of medicine was a resource that
brought pause and davinci interactive a
nationally recognized educational
technology leader together the vinci
interactive saul pauses strong network
and suggested interactive learning to
complement pauses online HIV news
interactive learning takes a topic that
is usually text-based and puts it into a
graphical multimedia format grabs the
users attention
it makes them become involved and make
key decisions really in the learning
process mesa Scuderi
is chief operating officer for da vinci
with content from NLM and pause his team
was able to create interactive modules
and characters at the forefront of each
story so we start with the content
that's there we pair that up with visual
concepts early on to see to make sure
that both are consistent and we bring
them together using interactive
animation sound
and just the flow through the learning
module itself and getting the user
involved in making key decisions along
the way the information from a source in
aids info was vital in creating each
module and its associated topic like the
aging module which guitarist says has
been especially helpful for him
from the aging module I think what I've
taken away from it the best is the idea
of self empowerment the idea of seeing
people like myself who are living long
term with the virus and how they've
gotten through the last several decades
feeling that they can talk to their
doctor feeling that they have
information enough to make treatment
decisions a partnership that connects
information and technology together to
help more people hear and see how to
live with HIV
[Music]
when you think of comic books or graphic
novels what immediately comes to mind
Batman Superman well for digital
illustrator my clearing he sees a tool
to improve somebody's life I am the
illustrator for this project and I also
wrote the scripts for this project which
is an HIV prevention campaign geared to
the Latino community the campaign is
called amigo de amante's and it's being
spearheaded by El Centro a nonprofit
organization that seeks to use
interactive graphic novels the novels
raise awareness of HIV and AIDS for
Latino MSM in New York City Latinos
represent just 17% of the population but
when it forms to the new cases of HIV
they do the same almost 25% of the cases
in the corner the entire process starts
with focus groups held with community
members an initial focus groups was
really about message development we said
these are the key HIV prevention
messages this is material that's posted
at the national library best web site
here's a broad picture of what we're
thinking we're gonna do it's gonna be an
online comic book with voices and speech
bubbles and sometimes there might be
choice points where the action will stop
and you'll decide for a character
whether they should or shouldn't do
something vital input from community
members coupled with the National
Library of medicines resources kickstart
the script writing and character
development process with a focus on
culturally relatable content they also
need information that is appropriate for
and that comes from their experiences
where the characters actually looked
like they that they feel identified with
those characters a task that was near
and dear to the heart of illustrator
Mike Leary having several Latino friends
and also living in Latino community in
wood in Manhattan it was very special to
me once the art was finished constant
development began a key focus was to
seamlessly integrate NLM health
education into the story what we came up
with what we call sort of a circle of
friends structure so there's one main
character and then these spokes that
come out from him so we know that he's
questioning he's in the city he's having
sex with men and with women but he's
also got a friend who's openly out and
he's got a cousin who's having problems
in her relationship harnessing the power
of compelling stories to inspire readers
to film and think deeply about health
issues that directly affect them nestled
between Philadelphia and Pittsburgh sits
the capital city of Pennsylvania
Harrisburg beyond having the unique
distinction as the training center for
the Union Army during the Civil War and
the present location of the National
Civil War Museum Harrisburg now serves
as home to a new organization fighting a
new battle black girl health black girl
health is a digital publishing company
our mission is to transform everyday
minority women into healthier
individuals we focus our efforts on
social media online commercials and
community outreach in 2015 black girl
health Assault great success on Facebook
using articles and creating a newscast
to disseminate NLM information and
resources as part of the pop the
question
HIV awareness campaign
pop the question is really just women
taking control of their sexual health
when you think of pop the question you
probably think of a man getting down on
one knee and asking their partner to
marry them instead this is the woman
maybe not getting down on her knee but
asking that man to go get tested using
HIV information from a source in
MedlinePlus BGH expanded their pop the
question campaign in 2016 to another
social media network frequently used by
the target audience instagram social
media assistant Ashley Manning converted
text-based NLM articles to short format
videos then publish those videos weekly
on the bgh instagram page for its
followers HIV is definitely a sensitive
topic
it's something that a lot of people
don't feel comfortable talking about
there's definitely a huge stigma around
HIV in the minority community so
bringing this information to them on
social media through video it makes them
feel more comfortable sharing it and
talking about it with others to help in
the fight to raise awareness vgh
recruited help from social-media
influencer miss Cheney and so how many
women have you been with ladies are you
unsure about your man's HIV status if so
it might be time to pop the question
visit black girl health calm today and
we'll show you how bringing comedy to a
topic that isn't fun to talk about
really made the content more engaged
capitalizing on the viral reach of the
video Mitch J instructed her following
to navigate to the BGH website where
they could fill out a survey evaluating
their knowledge of HIV and how to pop
the question they opened up the avenue
for us to have a dialogue about how to
pop the question when to pop the
question if you have popped the question
correctly
vGHS staff assistant Carlie Cureton
played an integral role in turning our
digital interactions with minority women
into real-world actions at black oral
health second annual kickstart Health
and Wellness Expo
we're here at the Kickstarter Women's
Health Expo and we're offering women an
option to get free from each other the
increased awareness of NLM's HIV
information on social media encourage
women to not only attend the expo but
garnered several on-site testings as
well showing once and for all in the
battle for minority women's health in
Harrisburg allies proved more powerful
than obstacles
[Music]
HIV is a tide the Tidewater region has
not been able to turn Norfolk State
University is helping lead the community
out of the rocky waters with project
choice project choice is an HIV
education and Prevention Program so the
choices for choosing healthy options and
challenging environments the university
program has focused on meeting the
health needs of African Americans by
using technology to access information I
think the mission of this project is
really in line with the overall mission
of project choice which is to not only
educate students and community members
that we engage with but to try to
prevent the spread of HIV to disseminate
information from the National Library of
Medicine engineer student Couture Cod
well created an iBook you're able to put
an iBook together through of course the
software iBooks Author Cod well says
multiple widgets are in the software
which provide the ability to include
interactive media such as audio and
video that the reader can play some of
which are recorded skits from theater
students okay you speak but what we six
what part is exactly like where my
intuition I can't help but feel as
though Oh men up to no good and I never
trying to actually listen to what you're
doing and what you're saying so I took
the role as being this ideal aggressive
woman
had been sexually harassed violated you
name protect yourself don't neglect
yourself eight info a MedlinePlus where
the resources used to bring context to
the scripts she became informed with the
prep the information of HIV how to go
get help
and who to talk to where to go so on and
so forth and her character changed so
embedded in the iBook are questions that
they ask and then they give you the
right answer to tell you whether you're
right or wrong
so that's embedded in several of the
chapters to make sure that people are
understanding what they're reading
project choice realizes the real test is
outside the boundaries of campus life
and in the community Cynthia Burwell is
tasked with taking the iBook to the
churches the church helps to reach the
people they will be trained on how to
use the iBook for Age AIDS and HIV
education in their churches they will be
able to use it with different groups in
their churches to provide up-to-date
information
NLM information that's helping give an
innovative lifeline to protect the
Tidewater community
[Music]
you have just seen how innovative
projects on the East Coast are fighting
the HIV epidemic with NLM educational
tools community outreach organizations
colleges tech and digital companies
print and online publications are all
playing an integral role in making a
difference so now we're going to visit
organizations and communities further
west starting in the Windy City Chicago
Illinois where there's an increase of
HIV AIDS related cases among African
American men at the close of 2015 more
than 24,000 people were living with HIV
in Chicago Illinois proactive a local
nonprofit organization is on the front
lines training and equipping community
health workers on how to deal with the
HIV epidemic
there are actually four institutions
involved two community-based
institutions and two academic
institutions one is south suburban
college and that's out here and that's a
two-year institution and the other is
Chicago State University these step up
students will eventually become
community health workers helping
residents by educating them on HIV
prevention and treatment methods through
the use of tablets I know that in the
future with the career choice that I've
chosen this is going to be a great tool
for me because the information that I
share will be from a reliable source
proactive will train 93 step up students
on NLM resources this will be part of an
interactive digital lesson plan
Interactive's healthcare readiness
program I thought that I had the
resources that I needed to talk about
HIV but as I began to go on this
particular website I learn more
and it was more truthful and accurate
information
the tablets community health workers
learn to navigate NLM resources on will
prove useful and off-site partner
organizations allowing them the
opportunity to meet people where they
are with vital and accurate HIV
prevention and treatment information we
have high-risk populations so they are
hard to find hard to locate but our team
has really been able to go in there and
do segmented outreach and locate those
individuals that are positive increasing
numbers of qualified health care workers
to meet the increasing need to treat HIV
patients on any given day one to two
hundred people pass through the Mexican
Consulate in Salt Lake City Utah and a
good portion of those people are just
waiting and there's absolutely nothing
there to do they just sit there and
stare at the wall pretty much so we use
that time with epitome of donair a
community health worker and they take
full advantage of it transforming
waiting time into a meaningful health
learning experience the biggest way that
HIV has affected our community members
is a fact that it's not something that
we talk about and it's not something
that we necessarily know about getting
pertinent health information from a
familiar face also makes a big impact on
those served cuando la mole información
park employee medellin + ayuda por
templo witches personas no tiene seguro
médico insufficient en la pagina Isola
I missed again it was icy let's say you
love a stunt and America mentos okay
this is no side the muslim numbers
raros since I say just efficient that
travels a information they may have
never come across due to the language
barriers they face in the US and
cultural barriers they face back home we
invite them into them and any other
salud to get tested we do blood pressure
glucose and BMI testing and at the end
of every person coming into getting the
testing we doing one-on-one session to
go over the websites again to reinforce
that these websites are available to
them to get hiv/aids info but also other
health related information they've
connected over 300 people to health
resources with the help of the National
Library of Medicine including Syria
Alvarez there is one website in
particular that anaconda showed me where
you can find like HIV testing places by
like putting in your zip code and it's
really cool from those surveys we've
been able to realize that the work that
our promotoras are doing is valuable and
it works because we see an increase of
knowledge from the before and after of
our committee members when they receive
the workshop and are able to access
their resources
assisting yet another person to their
right to life liberty and the pursuit of
healthiness
[Music]
of the year 2014 the transgender tipping
point from the red carpet and the runway
to politics and entertainment
transgender people truly were everywhere
but for many transgender youth the
notoriety has not created impactful
change in their daily lives nowhere is
that more apparent than in the area of
health care transgender youth they have
challenges they have requirements and
they don't know where to go to get a
questions answered they don't know where
to go to get services that are youth
friendly with providers that understand
the needs that are quite unique for the
transgender community headquartered in
the bay area of California the mecca of
LGBTQ rights whitey H is the partner of
choice for those in search of new ways
to advance health of youth and young
adults through technology in addition to
those health disparities youth are also
kind of faced with their depend on their
parents they don't necessarily have an
income so if they come out to their
parents and they're not receiving
support where do you go from there and
that is why they developed they choose e
a mobile app that brings together all
the Bay Area resources for transgender
spectrum youth so the design itself was
really guided by our brainstorming
process and meeting with the transgender
youth community and our advisory board
so that sort of kicked off the design
process where we got feedback from them
what they would like to see in the app
when somebody uses the app and they are
searching for a certain answer a certain
search term a lot of the resources that
end up coming up are actually NLM
resources the app is available in the
Apple or Android App Store and has
features that allow you to find
community hangouts testing sites and
doctors like dr. Scott Moser a
internationally renowned board-certified
plastic surgeon based in San Francisco
so any individual that's looking for an
HIV doctor again blood pressure doctor
or a diabetes doctor for any reason but
wants to make sure that their
gender-inclusive and an understanding of
their potential to their needs as well
those are the individuals of all be
easily happen giving Bay Area
transgender youth their moment for a
better life
[Music]
you have just saved the technical
processes each a CIO P awardee took to
disseminate NLM HIV information DaVinci
upgraded a conventional print magazine
with a scenario based a learning module
interwoven with resources from NLM elf
Centro used interactive graphic novels
to disseminate NLM information black our
health use an influential social media
celebrity to bring minority women
together to learn about NLM information
resources Norfolk State University
developed eye books that combined
Dramatic Arts with NLM information to
engage youth proactive community
services and gage students pursuing
health careers to use tablets to become
proficient with NLM resources
communities United use the Mexican
Consulate as a Technology Center to
educate spanish-speaking immigrants on
NLM resources and HIV information and
lastly why th served transgender youth
by developing a mobile phone app using
NLM information to meet the special
needs of this population after showing
all the technical approaches used to
disseminate NLM resources we hope you
see the awardees as key stakeholders
that align their efforts to address an
ongoing health crisis in addition the
National Library of Medicine as an
emerging leader in innovative approaches
to raising awareness around HIV and AIDS
we like to thank NLM for promoting
cutting-edge technology to support HIV
and AIDS prevention and treatment
information as well as supporting each
awardees creative uses of NLM's
resources
[Music]
[Applause]